in Syria the closure of schools because
of the corona virus pandemic is
affecting far more than how children
learn it's also making it much harder
for them to eat we estimate that around
368 million children around the world
are being affected at this moment
because they're not receiving school
meals because their schools are closed
the UN World Food Program and other
humanitarian groups are doing what they
can to continue distributing food for
the Syrian children and their families
in many cases these are the poorest
families that really depend on the fact
that their children are going to receive
this meal at school but getting
much-needed supplies to vulnerable
populations is posing a challenge travel
restrictions and border closures are
making it much harder to deliver aid
while workers on the ground in refugee
camps like Kakuma in northern Kenya are
introducing new physical distancing
measures to protect people against the
spread of covent 19 in Cox's Bazar
Bangladesh where around 1 million
Rohingya refugees live physical
distancing is nearly impossible
humanitarian agencies however say they
are trying their best in the delivery of
the humanitarian assistance itself we
have to be very very careful and
ensuring that we don't become part of
the problem but at the same time that we
are responding to people's needs and
hopefully preventing as much impact as
possible in places like the camps in in
Bangladesh where there are the most
vulnerable people in the world it's not
just the threat from COBIT 19 causing
concerns humanitarian operations that
are already happening before the kovat
19 outbreak need to continue there are
people who desperately need that
assistance and those operations are
there for a very good reason because
people depend on it
at a time of growing uncertainty for aid
workers one thing is clear the obstacles
they face and delivering help are
already great they will likely become
greater
Mohammed Jim Jim al Jazeera